et puis une bonne nouvelle venue de
dubaï la triple championne paralympique
thiam marie-amélie le fur a égalé hier
le record du monde de saut en longueur
de bonne augure pour les ambitions
olympiques de l'athlète loir et
chérienne romain delville un saut à 6 m
un nouveau record du monde marie-amélie
le fur commence très bien son année
paralympiques au grand prix
international de dubaï elle se présente
comme une des grandes favorites pour
tokyo on venait ici dans cette
compétition à dubaï avec deux objectifs
le premier c'était de faire une
performance pour remonter un petit peu
dans le mille bilan mondial qui nous
permet de nous qualifier pour pour les
jeux puisque l'objectif est d'être dans
les six meilleures mondiales ou bilan
qui sortira le 1er avril j'étais
actuellement troisièmes et ont souhaité
voir avec une performance au 2 août
autour des 5 85 5 90 1 plus vite plus
haute plus forte objectif tokyo 21 pour
marie amélie
et comme un bonheur n'arrive jamais seul
tiphaine soldés de l'a3 tours bat son
record personnel à 4 mètres 84 meilleure
performance mondiale des moins de 20 ans